25 يوم بتفصلنا عن نهايه 20 22 وحقيقه
يعني كانت سنحافله بالاحداث وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه اعطتنا ملخص للسنه عن طريق جوله
على 10 كلمات او عبارات تصدرت الاخبار هذه
السنه فخلونا ناخذ هذه اللفه مع بعض سواء
اولا نهايه العالم فمع اندلاع حرب
اوكرانيا والتهديدات اللي رايحه جايه
بالنووي والكلام عن حرب عالميه ثالثه
العالم غير مسبوق من سنوات طويله وكانت
نهايه العالم من اكثر العبارات المسيطره
هذه السنه
توثيق كلمه ثانيه سمعناها حتى يعني ملينا
منها بصراحه في الاخبار هذه السنه والسبب
طبعا قصه شراء ال ماسك لتويتر بكل تعقيدات
او مراحلها والكلام كثير عن شروط توثيق
الحسابات الجديده والوان وانواع جديده
للتوثيق قبل كل هذا طبعا الرسوم اللي يبغى
هافردها الثمانيه دولارات هذه اللي قلبت
العالم امراه حريه او امراه حياء حريه هذا
كان شعار الاحتجاجات المولعه في ايران من
شهور من وقت مقتل الشاب مهسا اميني على يد
شرطه الاخلاق وهذه العباره كمان تحولت
لشعار ابعد من ايران من محلي ومن حول
العالم صارت بتستخدم للدعم في الاحتجاجات
والمحتاجين والعباره كانت كمان من
العبارات اللي سيطرت على الاخبار في 20 22
ومع هذه العباره كمان كان في كلمه ثانيه
متعلقه باحتجاجات ماليه الاخبار السنه وهي
اوراق اي 4 لكن هذه الاحتجاجات كانت في
الصين وتحديدا ضد تشديد اجراءات كرونه من
جديد فساره متظاهرين بيحملوها دليل على
غياب حريه التعبير في بلادهم وحتى اون
لاين صاروا صينيين بينزلوا الصور مربعات
فاضيه دليل انه يعني مو مسموح لهم يقولوا
شيء وطبعا وفاه الملكه اليزابيث بعد 70
سنه حكم كانت من دون شك من ابرز احداث
السنه ومع وفاتها جسر لندن كان من اكثر
العبارات المتصدره للاخبار لك لانه عمليه
جسر لندن اوبريشن لندن بردج هو اسم الخطه
الموضوعه من سنين واللي بتناول خطوه بخطوه
وبتضمن الاحداث التاليه والمحدده لمراسم
وفاه الملكه
[موسيقى]
الفاشيه الجديده كانت من العبارات
المتصدره كمان في 20 22 وسببها وصول حزب
فرتل لديتاليه اخوه ايطاليا اليمين
المتطرف في الانتخابات التشريعيه وصولهم
للحكم ومع صارت جورج ملوني اول امراه تقود
الحكومه الايطاليه وطلعت تقارير عن
اعجابها وحبها للممثلين وفي امريكا ايضا
اذا انتقلنا الى هناك حنلاقي انه منح
المحكمه العليا كل ولايه حقها في حظر
عمليات الاجهاض او لا او اللي صار بعدها
من قرار 20 ولايه حظر الاجهاض واهميه هذا
موضوع في السياسه الامريكيه اصلا
والانتخابات كل هذا خلى عبارات رو ضد وعد
من اللي تصدر الاخبار هذه السنه وهو اسم
قضيه صدر فيها حكم في
1973 بانه دستور الولايات المتحده الدستور
الولايات المتحده عفوا يحمي حريه المراه
الحامل في اختيار الاجهاض دون قيود حكوميه
وهذا هو الحكم اللي الغى السلام
وايضا عندنا مع حرب روسيا واوكرانيا وازمه
الطاقه في اوروبا توفير استهلاك الطاقه
كانت عباره سمعناها في الاخبار كثير في 20
22 يعني بس تحديدا هذه السنه كانت سنه
اظهرت تسارع في التداعيات الكارثيه لازمه
المناخ وفي قمه المناق الشهر الماضي في
شرم الشيخ في اتفاق وصف بالتاريخي تم
التوصل اليه بشان صندوق اتسمى بالخسائر
والاضرار وبيهدف ل تعويض الخسائر والاضرار
المناخيه اللي بتعانيها الدول الاكثر فقرا
هذا الشيخ الخسائر والاضرار من اكثر
الاشياء اللي سمعناها في الاخبار في سنه
20 22
ومع الحديث عن المناخ مع انسى اكيد نتكلم
عن الجنون اللي شفناها هذه السنه الهجمات
واعتداء واحتجاجات غريبه من شطاء المناخ
والبيئه حول العالم والكثير من الاحيان
كان اعمال فنيه كبيره وخالده وكثير منها
اعتمدت على القاء حساء طماطم على لوحات
فنيه وعلشان كده احصاء الطماطم او شوربه
الطماطم كانت جمله سمعناها في 20 22 اكثر
من اي سنه ثانيه
[موسيقى]